this is a probably a lesser known story
to some of you guys but this is
absolutely wild Roald Dahl and he was
the uh the original well he's a he's a
writer was a writer uh for who wrote by
probably dozens of books right dozens if
not hundreds of books children's books
mostly uh who wrote Willy Wonka most
famously eventually the estate sold his
publishing rights and now the company
that bought the publishing rights art is
going in and changing to make things
more politically correct uh some of the
original works of doll it's rather
extraordinary so uh Samantha Smith had
this tweet up here it says Roald Dahl's
Publishers have made hundreds of changes
to his books claiming the language used
was offensive if you think this sounds
like something straight out of 1984 it's
because it is uh and there's a couple a
couple things here uh in the original
The Witches the line read don't be
foolish my grandmother said you can't go
around pulling the care of every lady
you meet even if she is wearing gloves
just you try it and see what happens
that was in the 2001 edition of The
Witches uh in the 2022 Edition it's been
changed don't be foolish my grandmother
said besides there are plenty of other
reasons why women might wear wigs and
there are certainly and there is
certainly nothing wrong with that I'll
just give you one more in the middle uh
also from oh you know I'll give you the
bottom one from Matilda which was a
great movie by the way great kids movie
she went
she went on olden day sailing ships with
Joseph Conrad she went to Africa with
Ernest Hemingway and to India with
rouyard Kipling and here's the new one
she went to 19th century Estates with
Jane Austen she went to Africa with
Ernest Hemingway and California with
John Steinbeck the point is whether you
think that these changes are cataclysmic
or not this is how art changes this is
how we we put our Val not our values but
the the values
of a really rotten Society on works of
the past that actually were pieces of
Art and if all of this if Matilda and
the witches don't affect you well yes I
said he wrote Willy Wonka this is wild
remember Augustus Loop remember the fat
German child who fell in the river of
chocolate got stuck
in that pipe right very sad story okay I
think he ended up in the mushroom not
the mushroom room the marshmallow room
horrible okay Augustus Gloop they are no
longer going to call him fat instead he
will be described as give me what is it
here he's going to be described as
enormous he will not be fat according to
the telegraph uh oh and the Oompa
Loompas are no longer small men they're
small people because we wouldn't want to
offend a female Oompa Loompa not that
anyone knows what a female is and to the
point of all of this as you guys know
that the wonderful I would say prophetic
what was once a work of fiction but
unfortunately has become reality George
Orwell's 1984 I thought this quote was
just perfect because this just this is
exactly what's happening in front of our
eyes this is this is the most famous
quote from 1984 of course every record
has been destroyed or falsified every
book Rewritten every picture has been
repainted every statue and Street
building has been renamed every date has
been altered and the process is
continuing day by day and minute by
minute
history has stopped nothing exists
except an endless present in which the
party is always right I mean my God does
it get more prophetic than that
[Music]
foreign